or à hermies faisait sawyer tous ceux
qui croisent leur chemin et elle pouvait
lui miner les moments les plus forts des
témoignages des souvenirs et des
chansons
pour être des proches ont pris la parole
pour rendre hommage à romy et nora
carpentier retrouvé sans vie dans un
boisé de saint-apollinaire le 11 juillet
toutes les fois que j'entends des cris
c'est mourir un seul homme comblé de
bonheur et d'amour
une cérémonie en toute intimité à
l'intérieur est projeté sur un écran
géant à l'extérieur n'aura remis ya palm
os en même temps il y en a tant pour
vous exprimer l'amour et le grand
bonheur de vous avoir eu près nous
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
défilé devant le complexe funéraire au
cours de l'après midi pour venir offrir
leurs condoléances aux proches des
fillettes
maintenant je comprends toute la nuit la
douleur elle commencera blood c'est
important d'être là pour la soutenir
puis on est quand même ses collègues de
travail on le côtoyait tous les jours
puis les filles on les connaît aussi
certains ne connaissent même pas les
familles mais tenait à être là on parle
de luan locale on est de la mauricie
c'est touchant les deux petites filles
est décédé comme ça pas de bons sénat on
se sent spontanément touché par ce qui
s'est passé fait que c'est ici ses
sentiments cette histoire a bouleversé
tout le québec et a ravivé la douleur
chez de nombreux parents qui ont vécu de
tels drames dans le passé c'est pas
facile de les donner un sens un
événement aussi dramatique que ça mais
c'est la seule façon de s'en sortir
à commencer par le sénateur pierre
hugues boisvenu qui tenait à être
présent pour livrer un message d'espoir
à la famille ses deux filles sont morts
tragiquement à quelques années
d'intervalle
qu'est ce qui reste après le drame de
même sinon l'espoir de retrouver ses
rêves de retrouver sa joie de vivre
parce que qu'on ne voit dire ces
familles là on a volé le futur de leurs
enfants
si le premier ministre n'était pas
présent la vice-première ministre du
québec a consacré les premières minutes
de son point presse pour offrir ses
condoléances aux familles des soeurs
carpentier toutes nos pensées sont avec
lui aujourd'hui particulièrement avec
leur mère bien sûr et la ville de lévis
a annoncé qu'une plaque commémorative
sera installé au parc des chutes de la
chaudière pour que remy et nora ne
soient jamais oubliés ici marie pierre
bouchard radio canada lévy